hey guys this is vidi with max tech and
this is the new iPhone 11 and today
we're gonna be comparing it to the old
iPhone 10 art from last year alright
let's get this guy in the box take off
this rap there you go
there she is wow this definitely looks
so different from the iPhone 10 R just
look at that whoa let's take it out of
the box and nice I really loved the
white on the iPhone 11 my second
favorite is probably the product red
right here but the white just looks so
classy I don't know just looks really
good
alright so let's get into the physical
differences first of all you guys can
see that the Apple logo goes down
towards the center of the phone and you
no longer get the iPhone text on the
bottom as you guys can tell you get
glossy glass on the back except for the
new camera bump you get this square
right here and it's all matte matte
glass just like on the iPhone 11 pro but
the pro has it on the whole back and the
square notch is actually glossy so it's
actually flipped but this looks really
really nice it's like almost like you
can barely tell that it's there but it's
definitely there and the microphone and
the flash go over to the right side and
of course we have the new auto I'd lens
camera that we're gonna be testing out
in just a couple of minutes now one
downside with the cheaper $700 iPhone 11
is that you get the old 5 watt charger
in the box unlike the iPhone 11 Pro that
gets the new 18 watt fast charger so
that definitely sucks but for a price of
$700 you really can't complain
now we also got the clear case for the
iPhone 11 which is really nice this was
available for the iPhone 10 our for the
first time alright so there you go here
it is with the case this is probably the
best case you could probably get for the
iPhone 11 just because of the colors on
the back they just look really really
good in the clear case really shows it
off and it shows off the centered Apple
logo which is really cool and of course
you get the square notch right there for
the camera lenses and what's really
interesting is that on the iPhone 11 Pro
the button layout down whereas here on
the iPhone 11 the
Leo is identical to the iPhone 10 are no
changes physically on the outside at all
except with the square camera bump and
the matte glass and this centered Apple
logo now let's go ahead and set it up
and as you guys can tell right here you
still get the same old notch no
differences at all in the display same
exact display no difference in
brightness quality nothing no changes
from the iPhones head arm so now that
the iPhone 11 is set up let's talk about
performance the new iPhone 11 has the
813 Bionic chip compared to the 812
Bionic in the iPhone 10 hour but here's
a pretty cool difference the a 13 in the
iPhone 11 actually has four gigabytes of
RAM compared to only three on the iPhone
10 are now this four gigabytes actually
matches the iPhone 11 Pro so you're
basically getting identical performance
to the iPhone 11 Pro for only $700
instead of a thousand or 1100 for the
max model so let's go ahead and run
hikage for right here we're gonna run
the CPU test first and there you go the
CPU test is finished and you guys can
see these scores right here this is
incredible you're getting over 13,000
multi score and almost 5500 single core
score on the iPhone 11 basically
identical to the iPhone 11 Pro and
you're getting much better scores on the
iPhone 10 are and what's cool is that
even with all this performance you're
still getting an hour more battery life
than the iPhone cenar which was the best
battery life in any iPhone last year so
this is really impressive to get this
much performance and battery life at the
same time and with that we're gonna go
back and we're gonna run the graphics
test and hear the results for the
graphics benchmark and as you guys can
see you're getting almost 50% more metal
graphics core which is honestly
incredibly because Apple said you're
getting about 20% better efficiency with
the iPhone 11s 813 processor and just
for good measure let's run another
graphics test this is an Tutu's
benchmark so the test is done and you
guys can see right here that we're
getting 440 mm score in antutu on the
iPhone 11 compared to 319 on the iPhone
10 are that's actually a really really
big difference and I think this score
completely blows away every single
Android phone out there it's really
really impressive
and we're seeing in these sub scores
right here the cpu is improved the GPU
huge improvement for the GPU and a
really big improvement for the RAM 13500
over ninety four hundred so that's
really really good news
Apple did say we're getting improved
speakers on the iPhone 11 with a new
true stereo surround sound kind of
software or something like that so let's
go ahead and test out the iPhone 10 our
first
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so one thing I'm noticing is
that the mids kind of feel a little bit
louder or more clear on the iPhone 11
and on the iPhone 10 are it's very easy
to pinpoint exactly where the sound is
coming from as I coming from a single
source like right in a single location
like right from the speaker but it seems
like the iPhone 11 is kind of mixing the
top and bottom speakers together and it
kind of forms like this source that's
like really broad and it sounds a lot
better and also the highs the high
frequencies sound a little bit louder
and more crisp on the iPhone 11 as well
and now let's finally get to the cameras
as you guys can see right here I'm
noticing that the iPhone 10 our white
balance is really cool like it's it's
totally messed up and the white balance
on the iPhone 11 looks really good so I
think Apple really made a lot of changes
to make the white balance more accurate
on the new iPhone 11 and as you guys see
we have a little button right here to
switch to the ultra wide lens which is
really really nice and another thing if
you kind of point the lens up you see on
the sides instead of having black bars
on the top and bottom you actually see
like a preview of the ultra light so
there you go see it kind of fits in has
this little animation and I think by far
the biggest deal is that the selfie
camera went from 7 megapixels on the
iPhone 10 R to 12 megapixels on the
iPhone 11 so I'm gonna take a selfie
photo and you guys let me know which one
looks better or if you see any
differences and something that's also
pretty cool on the iPhone 11 is that you
get a wider field of view on the selfie
camera so if you twist it into hers also
mode like that you see more of the frame
it kind of like does it automatically or
you could just hit the button and switch
it by yourself I'm also going to include
a photo like this for the comparison and
now let's get into night mode let's go
ahead and test out some photos so at
night mode it actually turns on
automatically as soon as it's dark
enough
and you actually get the option of
manually adjusting the duration of how
long it I guess it takes in lights I'm
gonna go ahead and show you guys a few
night mode photos as you guys can see
right now and just let me know what kind
of difference you see down in the
comments below and we also took a few
photo examples with ultra-wide versus
the regular wide camera so you guys can
see them right now and it's definitely a
really cool perspective to see it in
this ultra wide mode all right so let's
finish with my thoughts on that iPhone
11 last year's iPhone 10 R was actually
the best-selling smartphone in the world
for a couple of the quarters or at least
the first half of 2019 which is really
impressive and that's because of the
price it was seven hundred and fifty
dollars and you really got a lot of bang
for your buck but this year with the
iPhone 11 you're getting so much more
improvements like the 813 ship the extra
lens on the back the better selfie
camera a bunch of other features and
better battery life but this year you're
actually getting it at 50 dollars
cheaper at $700 so I think the iPhone 11
is going to be a complete blow out phone
it's just going to destroy a lot of the
market and people are gonna love it so
you can't really get a much better deal
than the iPhone 11 for $700 so I hope
you guys enjoy this comparison make sure
to drop a like down below click that
circle above to subscribe and check out
one of those videos right there make
sure to check out our f-111 pro
comparison to the iPhone 10s max thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]